as 15 days to slow the spread enters its
590th day rulers around the world are
becoming more brazen and open about the
political goals of this public health
lockdown in new zealand the prime
minister is now openly admitting her
ultimate goal which is a new social
hierarchy a new form of segregation
so you basically said this is going to
be like well it's almost like you
probably don't see like this the two
different classes of people if you're
vaccinated or if you're unvexed you have
all these rights if you are vaccinated
that is what it is so yep
that is what it is you got to give her
points for honesty all societies have
hierarchies okay sometimes the
hierarchies are according to class
sometimes according to race sometimes
according to money in america until very
recently it was according to merit now
the hierarchy depends entirely upon your
compliance with the whims of the ruling
class
on the bright side though as the left is
showing its true colors the right is
becoming increasingly less cowardly
at least in a few places willing to take
off the kid gloves to fight back i'm
michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from yesterday comes from
charlene who says every time i feel like
giving up homeschooling because it seems
impossible i just watch videos like
these to reiterate why i chose to do it
in the first place this is true it's
very hard to fight back against these
people who are taking away your rights
and your liberties and your way of life
because they just make it so convenient
to give them all the power and they make
it so inconvenient not to give them all
the power but we've got to fight back
that's the trap okay they've got the
stick they beat you with the stick but
they've got that carrot too it makes it
so easy do not let them do that okay
we want to preserve something we want to
have good memories we to pass on to
future generations good memories to look
back to when you want to look back to
some of those great memories i would
recommend you check out paint your life
i love paint your life i could not
possibly be more impressed with paint
your life what is paint your life you
send them a photo or multiple photos of
a loved one of a place of a special
memory and they will create a hand
painted picture of it for you i like
mine in oil but they have other options
as well
i will be completely blunt
i did not think this could be a good
service i figured the art would be
amateurish and not great
so the first time i got one done i had
it done for my step brother and then i
received the the hand-painted portrait
and it was beautiful it was incredible
so then i said i don't want all right
fine you can have this one because it
was of him and his wife but i said now i
want some for me i had one done of my
mother i'm having another one done now
it's just they're just beautiful they're
really and the price is unbelievably low
and it is such a special way to spruce
up your home have a cherished memory it
makes a great christmas gift at
paintyourlife.com there is no risk if
you don't love the final painting your
money is refunded guaranteed they will
work with you every step of the way you
can check on stuff right now is a
limited time offer you can get 20 off
your painting 20 off and free shipping
text michael mich ael to 64 000 that is
michael mich ael to 64 000
head on over to paint your life
celebrate the moments that matter most
term supply available paint your life
dot com slash terms how do you get it
text michael mich ael to 64 000. you
want to talk about brazenness you want
to talk about boldness the way the
ruling class here in the united states
especially is just wielding its power
hunter biden yes hunter biden
hunter biden you know he's that great
artist
he's the he started painting about five
minutes ago now he is one of the
highest grossing artists in the world
his art dealer is a man named george
belgium oh wow that sounds doesn't that
sound just like an art dealer george
belgium
was photographed on thursday
wearing a hat from camp david
camp david is the presidential retreat
that's the place where the president and
his family go to relax the sort of
private place for the president so we've
been told that hunter biden's
art career which has existed for exactly
five minutes has absolutely nothing to
do with joe biden it has nothing to do
with peddling influence has nothing to
do with bad actors around the world
trying to curry favor with the sitting
president
hunter biden's getting half a million
dollars for his doodles just because
people really like them or something and
so his art dealer
is wearing a hat
featuring the symbol of the presidential
retreat now
where did he get the hat did the art
dealer go to camp david
i don't know maybe he did maybe he
didn't that would be kind of a scandal
if he did actually go there did he get
the hat from hunter or joe biden i don't
know it'd be pretty scandalous if he did
that did he just have the hat made on
his own he's never been to camp david he
just had it printed up on a website
very possibly that's still a scandal
because the signal that he is sending
out there is i am close to the president
i'm so close to the president that i go
to his private retreat want to buy this
artwork
half a million bucks for some doodles
but imagine the influence that will
buy you and what are we doing about it
what do conservatives do about this well
i'll tell you what they do
here's a news report just came out
yesterday on monday a group of gop
members of the house judiciary committee
fired off a letter to attorney general
merrick garland demanding he fully and
unequivocally withdraw some memo that he
had written
i'm really not
criticizing members of the house of
representatives here okay
they're doing pretty much all that they
can do
but i have to tell you i am really
really sick of headlines
about
republican lawmakers sending other
people letters
i'm
breaking republican sends letter
to his political opponents
breaking
the opponents have to read the letter oh
wow guys was the letter strongly worded
oh boy that's going to show him god how
is merrick garland going to recover from
that you sent him a letter
oh boy the biden administration's on the
ropes man they're getting they're
getting letters from the house they're
getting letters from the senate oh boy
their afternoon is going to be ruined
depending on what adjectives you put in
that letter
i'm not going to do anything of course
so what are we supposed to do i'm really
not beating up on the house members here
because they just don't have any power
so
so they can hold hearings that don't
matter and they can write letters that
also don't matter
what we need to do if we want to affect
politics beyond hurting merrick
garland's feelings with strongly worded
letters is we need to win
elections and then we need to
fire lots of people lots of democrats in
the bureaucracy then we need to replace
them with our people and then we need to
wield power and exercise that power
strongly worded letters and a buck 50
will get you a cup of coffee
that's actually not true
in trump's america strongly worded
letters and and about 50 would get you a
cup of coffee in joe biden's america you
need like six or seven bucks because
inflation is through the roof and
there's nothing you can do about it
republicans unless you win elections and
kick out all your opponents and fill
those positions with all your supporters
and then wield the power
okay but we don't really tend to do that
very much
what happens is we occasionally win
elections and then we don't do anything
other than cut taxes
which is not going to help us retake
our country
now the strongly worded letter in this
case was focused on merrick garland's
decision
to target the concerned parents who have
been showing up to school board meetings
okay so the doj the attorney general had
sent out this
this letter accusing parents who show up
to school board meetings of being
domestic terrorists and so the
republicans don't like this so what we
need to do is not just right strongly
worded letters we need to win the
elections and stop this because what the
parents are doing is far more important
and effective than what most elected
republicans are doing and speaking of
those schools by the way that issue is
working for republicans there was a new
poll just came out from suffolk and usa
today
it was a poll of likely virginia voters
it was a poll on the approval numbers
for joe biden joe biden won virginia by
10 points in 2020 over president trump
right now joe biden's approval rating is
underwater
by 10 points in virginia just 42 percent
of virginia residents approve of joe
biden's performance 52 percent
disapprove
voters between the ages of 18 and 45 and
voters 65 and older were much more
disapproving of joe biden
than voters who were in the middle 46 to
65.
so joe biden's margin of victory in
virginia
was the largest for a democrat in in
virginia since fdr in 1944. some of that
might have to do with the way that they
changed all of the voting measures
what was the issue that mattered most to
people the issue that mattered most to
people according to this poll is the
economy that's almost always the case
39.6 percent of the people responding
said it was the economy so obviously joe
biden is screwing up there what's the
second biggest issue for people
education i said it yesterday you know i
hate to
say how right i am it pains me it's hard
to do it
but i said yesterday this education
issue is a huge winning issue for
republicans
second only to the economy right now so
run on it
you're seeing glen younkin the
republican candidate for governor
running on it right now against
against terry mcauliffe the once and
future governor the guy who's trying to
take his job back terry mcauliffe
running on a platform of parents have no
right to go to their kids school boards
parents have no right to influence the
curriculum we need to run on this this
is a great issue
okay
this is bad news for terry mcauliffe in
virginia in the short term but let's
learn this lesson don't just focus on
the stupid corporate tax cuts don't just
focus on
allowing allowing the schools to teach
whatever they want and yes critical race
theory is bad so we shouldn't make it
mandatory but it should be an option and
we should expand the curriculum and
include also no just ban it just ban it
desantis is doing this very effectively
in florida kick the stuff out of the
classroom fire the bad teachers fire the
bad superintendents get a little bit
tough
the liberal establishment right now is
trying to cover up corruption in
schools there was an incredible piece in
the washington post
do i have the no i don't have the story
itself all you really need though is the
tweet about the story
okay
so this is the washington post covering
the loudon county story
that's the story of a young girl who was
raped in a bathroom by a dude who
sometimes wears a dress who pretends
that he's a girl sometimes because of
the stupid transgender rules in the
bathrooms in loudoun county
here is the tweet from the washington
post
a teen testified that she met a
classmate for consensual sex in the
girls bathroom of a loudoun county high
school before
but in a may encounter she was sexually
assaulted new details in the case at the
center
of a firestorm in other words
she had asked for it
the washington post's hot take
on a story that they refused to cover
that we broke that the daily wire broke
about a girl being raped by a dude in a
girl's bathroom at a school with
transgender bathroom policies their hot
take is
she
had asked for it
absolutely
insane
absolutely insane stuff coming from
our
rulers right now i mean you can see you
don't need to look for these stories
even in the schools and the store you
can just see it every time you go to the
gas pump and when you go to the gas pump
i hope you save money with get upside
there has never been
a sponsor who has come on this show at a
more opportune time than get
upside what is get upside get upside
saves you money at the gas tank
right now our listeners are making up to
25 cents for every gallon of gas every
time they fill up just download the free
get upside app in the app store or
google play right now use promo code
knowles know w l e s get a bonus 25
cents per gallon on your first fill up
that is up to 50 cents cash back
do not pay full price at the pump
anymore get cash back using get upside
you download the app for free use promo
code nulls you can get up to 50 cents
per gallon cashback on your first tank
some people who drive a lot are saving
as much as two or three hundred bucks
per month they're getting it in cash
back there's no cash you can cash out
any time with a direct payment to your
bank account with paypal with e-gift
cards to amazon and other brands it's
just it's unbelievable do not leave
money on the table head on over to get
upside right now get the free app use
promo code knowles k w l e s
get up to 50 cents per gallon cash back
on your first tank you are welcome this
is my early christmas gift to you use
code knowles k-n-w-l-e-s
the washington post frames the story of
a young of what fifteen-year-old girl
getting raped by a dude who sometimes
wears a skirt in the girl's bathroom
they frame it as well they had had sex
before
they had had sex before so
so it was his right to have sex with her
again now
obviously the washington post is sick
and shameless this is a disgraceful
take on on the story
it does raise these questions so let's
answer these questions one does
previously consensual sex excuse raping
someone the washington post seems to
think perhaps
we would say no it does not there is
another question here which is these
kids were so young
they had had a relationship before
what led to this
i won't go into the details of of what
went on in this encounter but it was as
bad as it possibly gets okay
short of killing the girl it was as bad
as it possibly gets
how old is the kid 14 15 years old
what led him to this
what
what factors led to this i would
strongly
suspect that this kid is looking at
hardcore porn right i mean i suspect
about 99 of teenage boys are looking at
hardcore board it's everywhere there are
no safeguards on it and boys are curious
and their hormones are going crazy
some of the acts that he performed on
this girl i strongly suspect he first
discovered in the ubiquitous hardcore
port does that should we maybe regulate
that
i know the the kind of squishy answer is
no we can never regulate that seems to
me probably we should i'm not just as
i'm not blaming the victim like the
washington post is i'm not just blaming
porn but there are factors that led to
this maybe we should regulate that
maybe that's something conservatives
need to take up
speaking of crime and punishment though
violent crime is surging in minnesota
it's surged over the past year it's up
17 total setting records for murders
ilhan omar's take on this
got to blame the cops what
we must also recognize
is that the reduction in policing
currently in our city
and the lawlessness that is happening
um
is
due to two things
one the police have chosen
to not
fulfill
their oath of office
and to provide
the public safety they are owed
to the citizens they serve
right it's documented
but even before that it was documented
the minneapolis police department is the
most dysfunctional
police department
in our state and probably in the country
johann omar has such a sinister sounding
voice
that's beyond what she's actually saying
the way she talks it's like a movie
villain but what is she saying she's
saying
we must recognize that the reduction in
policing currently in our city and the
lawlessness is happening because the
police have chosen to not fulfill their
oath of office and protect the people
they said they'd protect this is this is
a big problem and she says the second
one is even before that it was
documented that the minneapolis police
department was very dysfunctional okay
but the thing is
she's pointing out that it's these two
problems
but we're focusing on the surge in crime
so when she says even before recent
events it you know the police part was
very dysfunctional okay but that's that
doesn't matter that's irrelevant because
we're talking about the change right
we're talking about the huge increase in
crime seventeen percent increase in
violent crime and new records for
murders so it's really just number one
ilhanov are saying the police are
refusing to do their job and protect
people what was ilhan omar saying last
year last year she said that the police
are a cancer and we quote we need to
completely dismantle the minneapolis
police department
do you get it yet
do you see this when the police do their
job and arrest criminals that is
terrible discrimination it's racist it's
evil it's white supremacy we need to
abolish the police okay then the police
don't arrest the criminals do you know
what that is it's racist it's white
supremacy they're not protecting people
they're not doing their jobs we need to
what do we need to do we need to
refund the police
what is it it's a rigged game is what it
is
anything the cops do
is evil and the cause of society's woes
there's nothing the cops can do right
now
that ilhan omar will not blame them for
it's the same thing with racism
you you notice this in particular
sometimes what the the left will say
if you
if you wear a sombrero
on halloween or cinco de mayo or
something that is cultural appropriation
if you
do your hair in a certain way if you
wear certain clothing that's cultural
appropriation that's racist
if you don't do that that's cultural
erasure so if you don't eat tacos on
cinco de mayo
if you don't
acknowledge these other cultures then
you're erasing then you're a white
supremacist because you're not
acknowledging mexican people or black
people or asian people
that's very racist
if you do
acknowledge those cultures you're also a
racist
because it's appropriating my culture is
not your costume or whatever they say
there's no way to win it's the same
thing with feminism do you remember i
remember this about three four years ago
no more than that now i guess
there was a big breaking shocking story
mike pence
that evil misogynistic my pants he
refused to cheat on his wife
so mike
big huge story mike pence would not go
on dinner dates with women who were not
his wife when his wife was not there
that's sexist
that ah
that's awful he wouldn't allow women
to rise up the ranks
he wouldn't he was treating women
differently than he would treat men
so you've got to go on dinner dates with
women but then by the way you go on
dinner dates with women and you're a
metoo predator sexist
there's no there's no winning it's a
rigged game
the squishes
very often
give in to this
the people who say i'm a republican but
not that kind of republican they always
i'm not a racist i'm not i'm not a
racist please i maybe we should reform
the police i must i'm not a
sexist i'm not
they don't care bro they don't care
ilhan omar doesn't care what the cops do
she's going to blame them for anything
these radical leftists don't care what
you white person or what you man or what
you
non lg bt elementop what you know you
straight person do they don't care
they're just going to blame you for
everything
so maybe you should just follow your own
moral compass your own conscience okay
and just do the right thing and stop
trying to play their game their game is
rigged
okay the upshot of all of this is that
we are not permitted to question our
rulers i saw a tweet that really summed
this up perfectly from mehdi hassan
mehdi hassan i take it is someone on
msnbc i've never seen him before but he
has a blue check mark he's on msnbc that
is my sister network that's where my
doppelganger
performs her show he was responding to
the conservative jesse kelly he said
quote
are you sure
you even understand what you're talking
about keeping unvaccinated people out of
public places is a
bolded
public health decision and not a
political decision
not sure why this is so hard for the
paranoid anti-science right to
understand good night
good night sir
neddy jesse is so much smarter than
those stupid conservatives like jesse
kelly they don't even understand this is
about public health not politics
do you think this guy has ever googled
the word political
i bet he has not
i bet he would be pretty surprised so i
said you know look maybe i'm
misremembering things let me i'm just
going to google the word political okay
to do political okay here's the
definition quote relating to the
government or the public affairs of a
country
so it's about public health
not politics
even though public health is is politics
it's the same thing whenever
any lib tells you something is not
political this is not political stop
making this political you can bet the
farm
that whatever they are doing is
extremely political and they themselves
are politicizing it
you can you can bet the farm on that
but what what medi-hasan really means
here is
this is not something you should be
allowed to question this is political
this relates to the public but you have
no right to question it
we need to outsource this to dr fauci we
need to outsource this to joe biden we
need to outsource this to me and all the
libs and you need to do whatever we say
when it comes to taking the fauchiachi
when it comes to how you can travel and
where you can go and when it comes to
wearing that stupid mask
you're not allowed to question it
and if you do you'll be kicked off of
social media you'll be kicked out of
your school you will be ostracized from
society you will be segregated like the
prime minister of new zealand says you
will be segregated you'll become a
second-class citizen
you will not be afforded the privileges
of the rest of society
now
the thing about this ruling class that
is not allowed to be questioned
is that
they're not exactly plato's philosopher
kings okay
these people who say we need to end
democracy we need to end our
constitutional republic
they don't have a whole lot to recommend
them
least of all the most exalted of those
rulers
dr fauci dr fauci just got caught in a
big lie we covered this yesterday he
lied in testimony before the senate he
said when he was asked by rand paul
have you funded gain of function
research
period but specifically in wuhan he said
senator paul
i have never we do not fund gain of
function research then rand paul said
well actually you have i have the proof
of this he goes well you know even if we
did it's totally fine but we that's not
what we do okay dr paul so now the nih
is involved in a major cover-up
because documents have proven that they
did in fact
engage in gain of function
research
the national institutes of health
have just changed their website
unfortunately for the national
institutes of health we have the
receipts which we'll get to in just one
second first though
you know what we do here at the daily
wire
the libs cancel people we hire those
people and we bring you their great
products well this just happened with
disney not even just because of gina
carano you know we're making a movie
with her after disney tried to cancel
her but with alison williams who was a
sports reporter for espn espn is owned
by disney uh allison williams refused to
take the fouchyache she voiced her
opinion espn is very upset about this we
think it's great so she's going to be
coming over to the daily wire
here at the daily wire we do not let the
leftist ruling class dictate our content
you dictate our content so head on over
to dailywire.com
subscribe
use the code do not comply save 25 right
now on a membership that is
dailywire.com subscribe save 25 on a
membership also subscribe and start
listening to morning wire it's a great
new show it's our answer to the left's
morning news shows where the left takes
you know 15 minute news shows
these really quiet voices
they they make you they really calm you
down and then they cram a bunch of
leftist propagandists you say hello
welcome this is the new york times i'm
michael bubba
and the conservatives are bad
and the leftists are really good
and i'm ba-ba-ba-ba with the new york
times and so we're giving you just the
facts in the morning tune in it's a
great show we have beaten them on the
charts which we love subscribe we'll be
right back with a lot more
the national institutes of health
funded gain of function research in
wuhan china they then lied about this
they lied about funding it period and
they lied about funding it specifically
of course in wuhan
now they are editing their website to
cover up the gain and function section
unfortunately for them
we have the internet and the internet is
forever so if you go right now to the
nih website to look updated function
nothing is going to come up
if you go to archive.org
to look at the old version of the
website a whole lot is going to be
coming up
it's going to talk to you about how gain
and function research describes a type
of research that modifies a biological
agent so that it confers new or enhanced
activity to that agent
some scientists use the term broadly to
refer to any such modification however
not all of gain of function research
entails the same level of risk and then
they go on and have this nuanced
discussion
what dr fauci is trying to do right now
to avoid
demonstrating that he perjured himself
is he's trying to say that what he
engaged in which is gain of function
research is not really gaining function
research because he didn't know that it
was going to be really bad what is gain
of function research it's when you go in
and you modify an agent to make it
deadlier or more powerful or more
transmissible or or enhance its function
in any way
it gains function
so dr fauci what he's trying to say is
no no no if we take a bat coronavirus
and we make it way deadlier and way more
transmissible that is not gain and
function research if we didn't mean to
do it whoopsie
if we didn't know for certain that that
would happen what are you talking about
the point of the research is to figure
out
if you are enhancing its functions if
you are
making them if you're diminishing the
functions if nothing happens at all
increasingly
this is looking not just like
incompetence there's plenty of that
there not just like ignorance there's
plenty of that there increasingly it's
looking like
a cover-up
that's a cover-up what do you call it
when you go on and change your website
and
erase all of the information that shows
that you lied and purged yourself that
to me is a cover-up
dr fauci
is digging that hole further and further
for himself right now and not only
should he be fired but he should be
thoroughly investigated
at least
speaking of covering up
joe biden is showing how silly all of
these coveted measures are
he was just
rattling on and on about i don't know
corn pop or something and then
he well just take a listen to the clip
[Applause]
so joe biden finishes a speech he coughs
into his hand
now we're told remember obama first told
us you have to cough into your elbow
never cough into your hand
especially during an epidemic an alleged
pandemic
he coughs into his hand and then what's
the first thing he does
he shakes people's hands
so all of the people around joe biden
are wearing masks joe biden is not
wearing a mask because the masks are
extremely stupid
he then coughs into his hand that's kind
of yucky and then he immediately shakes
people's hands and you know you know
what folks
everyone in that picture is going to be
fine biden's going to be fine the guy
who's handy shook is going to be fine
the stooges and the masks they'll be
fine too
but it does expose
the hypocrisy
and the frivolity of this the covid
hysteria
is
purely instrumental
the 590th day of 15 days to slow the
spread the purpose of that day is not to
protect the public health
it's not to save lives how dare you
killers you don't want to save lives it
is
as the new zealand prime minister said
to create a new hierarchy
a segregated society new classes of
people
it is to empower the people who have
taken more and more and more of our
rights and our freedoms and our way of
life over the past year
and people are sick of it not just the
republicans not just the rock ribs
conservatives ordinary people pro
athletes guys like floyd mayweather
floyd mayweather who comes out
as there is a huge controversy around
the basketball player kyrie irving
who won't get the vaccine he's being
benched now floyd mayweather comes out
he says hey buddy great job
kyrie what's up i know you're going
through a lot
we had a chance to hang out in 2016 when
you represented america when you
represented the red white and blue
you only want to be treated fair you're
a great person great father
a great athlete
and you believe what you believe
america is the land of the free freedom
of speech freedom of religion and
supposedly freedom to choose
never be controlled by money i respect
you for having some integrity and being
your own man
a free mind makes his own choices and
enslaved mind follows the crowd
stand for something or fall for anything
one man can lead a revolution to stand
up and fight for what's right one choice
one word one action can change the world
it's crazy how people
hate you for being a leader
i hope your actions encourage many
others to stand up
and say enough is enough
respect to you kyrie
and power to the people
now i love this message
i'm not gonna
flatter people though all right what
floyd mayweather just said is a bunch of
platitudes it's a bunch of slogans
enough enough is enough power to the
people
you're free be free right it's all this
really basic stuff that is not
particularly profound it's not deep
political
thinking
but i still love this message and i love
the courage that it is taking him
to stand up and say this and i think the
gop has a big lesson that it can learn
here which is when you were going out
when you were conveying a message i'm
not talking about when we have debates
i'm not talking about when we're
formulating our plan when we're
strategizing i'm not even talking about
on podcasts such as this or in think
tanks or in the room of advisors i'm
talking about when you are just
communicating
your plan for america
keep it simple buddy
be like floyd mayweather here
where he says what do we know what do we
know about the vaccine
it's experimental it's
it has had side effects it has killed
people you say in rare cases but that's
why they paused the johnson johnson
vaccine because
people were dying from blood clots it
does entail risks all vaccines all
medical interventions entail risks and
for the vast majority of people the
coronavirus is just not that deadly it's
just not
that dangerous for for some people it is
for most people vast majority people
it's not
so
let's just say hey guys make your own
decisions hey be prudent hey guys we
have a tradition in america of people
making their own decisions on these
sorts of things
the democrats are going to say well
actually you know if you look at the
statistics and you look at the numbers
and then but and we know that the
scientists all say the backseat is
totally fine
yeah right but we know on a gut level
this is wrong
we know on a gut level when we listen to
the prime minister of new zealand say
she's going to segregate her citizens we
know that's wrong okay we don't we don't
like that we don't want that
keep it simple
yeah we want freedom stand up do what's
right enough is enough power to the
people i hear you i hear you floyd i
agree
now
there's a higher level of this which is
how do we beyond the cultural sphere
exercise our political
rights when we have them a lot of
republicans they just twiddle their
thumbs they don't do anything when they
have power there's at least one guy down
in florida who is doing a great job that
would be ron desantis
in terms of the governor's right now
he's doing better than any other
governor in the country and one of the
smartest things he did on coronavirus is
not just write executive orders it's not
just give good speeches he is installing
people in important positions
who are able to effect his agenda one of
those guys is the new florida surgeon
general
a guy who is saying this coveted
hysteria is ridiculous
we are not going to buy into it anymore
i've heard some leaders say things like
we'll create safe workplaces by
mandating these vaccines
well
they're really decoupled
because the infections can still happen
whether people are vaccinated or not i
mean that's very obvious you know and
you remember these people were also
telling you that all these breakthrough
infections that people on you know
sports stars and celebrities and your
neighbors and maybe you were having
after you were vaccinated were rare well
they're obviously not rare in fact
they're common and so and so that's the
truth so this idea that the vaccines are
needed to create the vaccine mandates
are needed to create safe workplaces is
to complete lie it's continued to be
repeated and you should know that it's
not at all backed up by science in fact
the science says something that's
completely the opposite so and that's
the fact
so
what the florida surgeon general is
saying right now is something that
conservatives have been saying for a
very long time but he has more
credibility okay ron desantis could have
said
those very same things in fact i'm sure
he has said those very same things
but he recognizes he can't go it alone
you've got to play the game a little bit
here beyond i mean i'm really pleased to
hear what this florida surgeon general's
saying but beyond that what it's showing
me is that ron desantis has
very sharp political skills
it might be ridiculous that we live in
the kind of country right now where you
need some egghead to tell you basic
things where people are deferring to
doctors and bureaucrats but that's the
country we live in and so desantis is
not going to ignore that he's going to
play that game and he's going to do it
for good for the good reason
it
doesn't hurt i i don't like identity
politics it doesn't hurt that the
florida surgeon general is a black guy
why does it not hurt because the left is
going to cry shriek white supremacy and
this is a
terrible racist man and so when he's a
black guy kind of takes that off the
table i'm not saying we should always
give into that we should always play
that i'm not saying he was picked
because he's black he's obviously got a
very keen insight into this sort of
thing he's obviously a very capable guy
with stellar credentials but from a
political perspective it doesn't hurt
all right
beyond the virus stuff this shows me ron
desantis knows how to play the game and
this is something that republicans need
to learn the lesson on here
okay there are a lot of to zoom out
forget about the virus for a second to
zoom out there are a lot of
conservatives who say it is wrong
for us to wield the executive agencies
when where it is wrong for us to govern
by executive order it is wrong for us to
have activist judges it is wrong for us
to because
by golly in my 19th century vision of
american government that is not how
things are supposed to be done
we should not have the administrative
state what fdr did it was awful what
wilson did it was terrible and so we're
not gonna wield that power
oh okay cool bro that's well enjoy play
acting enjoy larping
enjoy pretending that we live in a
country that has not existed for 100
years
because what the libs are going to do is
wield power in the country that actually
exists today
so they're going to win
and we're going to lose but what are we
we're gonna lose with dignity i guess
that's what that's what these people
tell us
or
you can
live in the actual political realities
that we're we're in right now
and you can use them to your advantage
and try to beat
the left
all right this is a power grab and
politics it's not exclusively about
power
but
in many ways it's about power
and so
what does that power grab look like when
i first heard that new zealand prime
minister at the top of the show say
you bet you bet we're segregating people
you bet we're creating new classes of
citizens you bet we're creating new
hierarchies that's sent to chill down my
spine i thought are we living in some
dystopian future but
but that was not nearly so spooky as a
story that just came out of hawaii
in hawaii right now
the government is using
robot dogs to patrol homeless camps
and
and scan their heads and make sure that
none of them have a fever
and if they are they will intervene
as part of the
covid
public health tyranny that is like
terminator stuff that is like robocop
stuff that is stuff that i did not know
existed in reality and apparently it
does these robot dogs
are equipped with cameras two-way
communication artificial intelligence
autonomous data collection capabilities
and scanners that scan your eyes to
detect for fevers
then they interview people who have the
fevers and test positive
this is very spooky and it's very
inhumane
one we shouldn't be tolerating homeless
camps
we are tolerating them increasingly
around new york around austin around
los angeles and all these places
but that is in
human and in
humane
all right two we shouldn't just be
interacting with people through robots
james pulas over at the claremont
institute he has this idea that
transgenderism the crazy transgender
focus right now is actually just a foot
into transhumanism
that it's
it's about transcending our humanity
uploading everything to the cloud this
is this is wrong this is the sort of
thing it might be more efficient
you know we've had this debate on the
right for a long time might be more
efficient it might increase gdp it might
make markets work better but it's just
inhuman i
here's my bold claim i don't want to
live in a country run by robot dogs okay
speaking of robots got to get to this
clip i've been putting it off for a few
days
i'm not sure that joe biden is a human
because he hear me out he was on cnn
just talking to anderson cooper
he looked
he looked like a robot he didn't know
what to do with his hands take a listen
just in terms of inflation because you
had told
us at a town hall i think it was in july
that the in this was just near-term
inflation
so joe biden just standing there got his
hands up he doesn't it's like it's like
that scene in 30 rock where alec baldwin
i don't know what to do with my hands
joe biden doesn't know what to do with
his hands
joe biden is obviously not all
there
okay
but
the scarier part is not just that we
have a guy who's doesn't have a whole
lot going on between the ears running
the country the scary part is the people
who are actually running the country we
don't even know their names okay they're
just part of the blob they're just part
of the establishment they're just part
of the new ruling class and the new
social hierarchy that is taking power
more and more and more
and more
you're seeing this at
the department of the treasury
janet yellen right now the treasury
secretary has revealed that this will be
there will be a new counselor for racial
equity starting at the department this
week
this person is janice boldler boldler
will be charged with coordinating
treasury's efforts to advance racial
equity including engaging with diverse
communities throughout the country to
identify and mitigate barriers to
accessing benefits and opportunities
with the department why do i mention
this i mean treasury is doing a lot of
stuff right now behind the scenes that
is
messing with our economy there janet
yellen is now saying after she told us
that the inflation was going to be over
within months it's going to be going on
for for at least a year but it's no big
deal don't worry it'll it's okay
why does it matter that they have a
counselor for racial equity because this
is the secular version of a chaplain
okay in the old days you would have a
chaplain to deal with the religious life
in
ostensibly non-religious circumstance
you have a military chaplain for
instance universities have a chaplain
you could have a chaplain
in your workplace depending on what
institution you work for now we don't
have that at harvard the chaplain is an
atheist
right people were shocked you why how
could the chaplain be an atheist well
because
the
official religion is now secular so we
don't have christian chaplains we have
atheist chaplains and really the
chaplain
is the director of diversity and
inclusion and equity that is the
religion that that transcends the
partisan differences okay sometimes we
talk about the regime on this show what
do we mean by the regime
we mean
the things about our government that
don't change
regardless of the election
maybe the republican wins we're still
gonna have a counselor for racial equity
maybe the democrat wins we're still
going to have a counselor for racial
equity
okay
this is just
now in the air it's just the building
block
okay and that this is the thing we need
to challenge because this ideology of
equity and inclusion and diversity
is very contrary to the american idea
okay it creates these bizarre
intersectional hierarchies and undercuts
constitutional government it takes away
a lot of our rights the authentic right
of the people to run their own politics
it's a real threat and it's not going to
change
unless we when we are given political
power go at it
tooth
and nail
okay it seems frivolous but these people
mean business
janet yellen right now is proposing one
of the most radical measures that i have
seen
in politics and because she's kind of
boring and because treasury is kind of
boring because economic stuff is kind of
boring people aren't paying attention to
it right now what they are proposing
is
taxing
your assets
that have not been realized yet
i think what's under consideration is a
proposal that
senator wyden and the senate finance
committee have been looking at that
would
impose
a tax on unrealized capital gains
on liquid assets held by extremely
wealthy individuals billionaires
i wouldn't call that a wealth tax but
it would help get at
capital gains which
are an extraordinarily large part of the
incomes of the wealthiest individuals
and
right now
escape taxation
until they're realized and often they're
unrealized and that death uh benefit
from a so-called step up of basis so
it's not a wealth tax but
a tax on unrealized capital gains of
exceptionally wealthy individuals
now you know i'm i make fun of
republicans a lot for only focusing on
tax cuts and shrieking every time
there's a potential tax hike
what what janet yellen is proposing here
is not just raising taxes a little bit
on the rich i'm fine with that i don't
care if some woke ceo who has no loyalty
to my country and who's peddling a bunch
of crap gets taxed more that's fine by
me i really don't care all right the the
wealthy in this country seem
disproportionately to be democrats so
that's fine tax him whatever
what is being proposed here though
is taxing
unrealized gains
and the thing about unrealized gains is
they're not real
and they haven't this would be
like saying okay you've got some stocks
and then you're let's say you've got uh
bitcoin or something right or uh one of
these crypto stocks and then it goes up
a lot so on paper you've made some money
you haven't actually made the money you
just own some of this stock what janet
yellen is proposing is going in to these
investments and forcing you to pay taxes
on them but you don't have the cash to
pay taxes on
so you've got to sell the stocks
to pay
the tax so what is that going to do to
the market
first of all it'll
seriously distort
these the investments
period right it'll seriously if everyone
come taxis and has to start selling off
their whole portfolio to pay for the
taxes that is going to throw the markets
into a frenzy
but also it's just a huge power grab
because it's not even taking money that
you currently have
it's taking it's taking money that you
might have in the future it's cutting
off your ability to make this kind of
money at all
all right and it's and they're doing it
through all of these different measures
all right they're doing this through
the diversity and equity and inclusion
ideology that's infiltrating colleges
and board rooms and the government and
everywhere they're doing it through your
bank account they're trying to take your
unrealized gains they're trying to give
the irs the ability to look at all of
your bank transactions if you've got
more than 600 bucks in your bank account
that's not the millionaires and the
billionaires that's everybody
they are now going in and telling you
you can't leave your home they're
telling you you've got to wear this mask
they're telling you you've got to take
the fouchy out here you'll be segregated
you'll be a second class citizen it is a
massive power grab to create a new
hierarchy
and all societies are going to have
hierarchies the question is what kind of
hierarchy do you want to live in do you
want to live in something similar to the
traditional american understanding of
this were merit counts where hard work
counts whether people still have a say
in their government or do you want to
live in the left's world where
you are not allowed to question the dr
faucis where public health is not
political where janet yellen is not
political where joe biden for goodness
sakes is not political
and where you are ruled
by
these radical radical people and your
position in that hierarchy is determined
by just how much you are willing to
comply i'm michael nolan the michelle
show see you more
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 21.
on the matte wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture faith current
events all the fundamentals if they
matter to you come check out the show